hello and welcome back to work plates
and blowers um just a moment ago okay
we're playing them closed Catalan
opening generally considered to be quite
comfortable for white but it leads to
complicated play okay my day six not
sure that's necessary but I'm
threatening before here and black cannot
play c5 I take f6 play Knight g5 it
should be seven this is some okay let's
think about this for just a moment
yeah there's still no c5 it's important
to understand that if I managed to play
c5 in this position blacks game would be
extremely cramped so it does not really
matter with you really that looks
extremely odd like just running into 95
I mean okay a d4 is hanging what takes
it we should be to go
you're supposed to survive this that is
crazy okay it's it's kind of unnecessary
to actually calculate here because this
is just better form without any any
trickery
okay now I'll going no I'm going to do
them he can absolutely not take I think
we should be to Queen d8 group doesn't
work okay maybe just work action
okay I can always take on c6 huh hmm
still not super convincing
okay just moves it away huh 96 they
cannot be five probably mm-hmm okay
okay now how to how to improve this
pollution we can further centralize but
the other thing is okay oh wow I'm kind
of shocked that is killing off the whole
structure for for nothing basically yeah
now basically winning everything here is
six and so on Bishop h3 is coming some
absolute absolute disaster 96
yeah just recapture basically keeping
all the ideas in place
now I could play 96 of course but he has
gotten away out of this on top of
everything I have Bishop age three
coming that is the the biggest most
serious threat actually okay um take
only six well this first now take on e6
he also has very few squares for the
Queen
hmm where'd you go now okay yeah Bishop
takes d4 okay I have no time actually I
should keep that in mind I only have 15
seconds okay let's do something simple
and it was by far by far not the best
she was just taken some material
yeah this is still better but in
comparison to what I had it's it's
pretty awful
yeah c-pawn should decide
okay can run my own pawn
the bishop is covering the H pawn
yeah that was pretty bad
you know I I just just take some
material there I was so much like
enjoying the good position that they did
not really pay attention to winning it
okay so got this and I'm already very
skeptical about this if you don't get c5
and blacks position becomes really
really bad and stockfish is already
also on a pretty high evaluation okay
rook c8 yeah before you can never do
this because of this thing threatening
maid and here at the end it's an awful
double attack okay so I could play 95
and I was thinking it you know I wasn't
quiet you know this I saw and then I saw
this and rook and Queenie Aid and I
wasn't totally certain if that wins the
engine however is very merciless and of
course finds this then winning the
exchange with an ongoing initiative
which is winning completely okay c5 is
also a pretty big advantage but not as
good obviously now I went 95 when I felt
he cannot take it
my idea was rook to e1 but that is
actually not so great this seems very
dangerous though threatening here with
all kinds of moves like Knight g4 and c6
is hanging so it is a very good position
okay he went Queenie aid and okay when
f5 is yeah you're already in very bad
shape anyway with f5 Wow okay now I was
just thinking about piling up on on e6
and now I should just take
stuff I mean I can't take take material
here take take material and win the
thing I was too much focused on ya
enjoying the position basically okay
this was this was an immediate win why
why actually ah it's funny yeah yeah I
have this it's not a very common motif
okay Bishop c1 I mean this is keeping a
big edge but it's not as big as it
should be and when we were here in this
ending it's a clear advantage but the
game continues and it again it shouldn't
you know ok rupee 3 was bad Bishop c1 is
stronger I just felt that this is easier
to play and so it must be very strong ok
e4 I'm sorry he for was good that's true
the engine spots this tactic immediately
pushing the pawns home ok but I don't
think it matters that much I had a
winning position till the end some
inaccuracy so it's nothing particularly
substantial ok guys thanks for watching